Hi! I'm Miriam and I'll be the assistant instructor for CS222.
Now, I personally think that Math matters a lot but I know there's some skeptics out there
so hopefully by the end of this course you'll know better.
This is the first course that I'm working at Udacity and I'm really, really excited to be part of it.
Aside from the fact that I really love Math and Physics and learning about pretty much anything,
I'm a yoga teacher and I really love to bake anything. I'm not really into cooking though.
I really only like baking sweet things like pie and cake and brownies and cheesecake
and kind of anything that taste good.
In terms of this course, I'll be helping you guys out on the forums
and by filming to explain the problem sets.
So now that you know a little bit more about me, I'm looking forward to seeing you in the forums
and good luck in the class.